use aids
if you're struggling to learn something
new make it easy for yourself give
yourself an aid to help you
here's what i mean by that when i was
learning the snowboard one of the things
that helped me was i got
what we referred to as ass pads and
basically what i did was i got a yoga
mat
and cut it out and glued it on the
inside of my snow pants it's actually
velcroed but anyway whenever you fall
down it doesn't hurt so it makes the
learning experience a little less
painful
when i did my videos i used to always go
before the video i would always go out
and buy a huge ice cappuccino so i would
get like this humongous drink it had
tons of caffeine tons of sugar and i'd
like suck that down and then get onto my
videos and it gave me energy and
excitement because i found it was hard
at sometimes
i'm by myself right i mean wherever i'm
at i'm by myself talking to a camera
and
i found that that gave me extra energy
and before every radio show would do
that too
and today was the first day
that
i didn't go out and get the drink
i just
i didn't need it you know i've been
doing it for a while i got the
confidence
and
didn't feel like i needed it so i just
started recording it was great and when
i snowboard i don't need to go out with
my
ass pads anymore because
i don't fall as much
and so when you're learning something
make it easy for yourself and and
you don't don't worry about if people
are are calling you out or saying you
look stupid or whatever you're learning
right you're you're taking a step where
they're not willing to when i have my
ass pads on my ass looks huge it's like
what is that guy wearing but it helped
me learn
because if i kept falling and falling i
didn't make progress i might have quit
so whatever you need to do to get to
where you need to go even if you look
stupid for a while do it it's worth it
use the aids make it easy for yourself
and at some point you'll get enough
confidence and enough skill
that you won't need anymore
you give it up
and you just could do your thing
believe
those are watching like the video thumbs
up below thank you so much i love those
coming in and let me know what you think
leave a comment ask a question i'll make
a video response thank you so much i'll
see you soon